[Music]
reject nation it's Greg every angry
dudes though video yeah gonna watch the
tree we're gonna watch the trailer for
creed 2 today people I'm excited to
check this out I'm really anticipating
this job watch Creed 2 for the first
time last night
I watch Creed 2 one time opening weekend
before we do that I want to say thank
you to everyone who has bought tickets
already to our live event that we are
hosting July 7 Saturday 6 p.m. at the
arena Cinna lounge movie theater on
Sunset Boulevard it's a live film
therapy event Brianne Chandler will be
there helping us host it Stacey Howard
as well there's gonna be a QA we're
gonna be screening a lot of our favorite
movie clips but were there a fun
meet-and-greet where we get to hang out
with all you guys who are attending
limited seating so go get your tickets
now link in the description box and
speaking of which wanted to give a shout
out to David Gandy David Gandy lives 6
hours away from us and he is gonna be
driving all the way down here already
got a message from him saying that he
has booked a hotel not far from there
and he is gonna be paying us a visit
just so he could attend the live event
so David its troops like you that helped
keep this channel running love you buddy
can't wait to meet you in person my dude
and can't wait for you to train me of
how to box cuz this is boxing movie
[Music]
he's just like a Paolo
[Music]
in the ring you got rules not say you
got nothing
life hits you with all these cheap shots
people like me live in the past you got
people that you need you know you got
everything the loose
this guy's got nothing to loose ain't
got a choice nice to say that your
father said he died right here in my
hands he said meet this guy right there
dangerous
[Music]
[Music]
kickbox rewrite history don't pretend
it's about your father
[Music]
that's cool I want to rewrite history
[Music]
it may not seem like it now but this is
more than just fight
[Music]
there is okay all right okay so I'll
admit when I heard Ryan Coogler wasn't
returning I was a little bit worried
when I heard that this was gonna have a
plot of him bursting Ivan Drago's son I
was a little bit worried yeah this is
just gonna be a rocky movie for all I
know this could just be a really good
first trailer I love that it still feels
very Creed centric it still feels like
this could be a necessary chapter and
this kid's life is it good like my age
if you don't know the plot description
before watching this trailer they only
teased Drago at the end that might be
the son of Ivan Drago I like the concept
of him saying I wanna be right history
because spoiler alert Apollo Creed died
in rocky 4 from the hands of Ivan Drago
this concept of you know the sons
inheriting the sins of their fathers
there's something Adonis Creed and then
I don't know I haven't Drago's Jeff them
going up against each other having to
like live in their parents history is a
cool concept I could also see how that
is a very frightening situation for
rocky to be and yet side we lost one of
his best friends and no matter what
you're gonna be kind of in that
headspace no matter what yeah for Rocky
especially because so much of what rocky
brings to [ __ ] and I imagine to this
movie too is just that experience all
the knowledge the intimate knowledge of
those fights having the kids verse each
other seems like it could be a sort of
tall order and dry what are the odds but
at the same time I feel like with the
right handling this could be great I
mean I don't really see a direction that
looks all too different for Ryan Coogler
here the aesthetic the cinematography
and it's the debate in my head I would
like a Ryan Coogler esque film and at
the same time
I'm gonna do is okay yeah they're gonna
feel like it naturally flows out of the
first movie and yet I kind of want to
see whoever's directing this bring their
own flair to it and yeah put their stamp
on yeah yeah and I think it is a natural
progression because the first movie
doesn't really have this like main
antagonist like you do have an
antagonist but it's not really about
creed versus whoever that dude is you
know Creed versus himself yeah this
trailer is setting you up for a very
specific match a very specific fight all
that it means to him in a very emotional
way that him winning this match means so
much to him for rewriting history so
this story has a great set up in an arc
for creed already you know he has his
exterior goal just gotta win the match
hopefully that'll allow him to overcome
some you know whatever weight he's
carried from the past of being Apollo
Creed's son coming off the first movie
to have this be the second fight like
the stakes are that much higher to
actually see Creed full-out
win the fight yeah I know and I don't
know if it's probably doing like a like
a rocky 3 thing as well it looks like
kind of a hybrid of Rocky 3 and 4
because I'm the rocky 3 early on in the
film rocky gets his ass handed to him by
mr. t and then it's all about that
rematch and having that ultimate fight
and redemption and it'll kind of
combining Drago and and then show at the
beginning of the trailer of him losing I
wonder if it's kind of a hybrid of that
those two plots the theme of the low
pass to Creed's have been this kid
living in the past
hmm and carrying the weight of his
father's legacy yeah that's definitely
fair something tells me rocky will die
in this one there I could also see I'm
that I feel like Rocky might I I think
it would be a good time for Rocky to die
let's get more Rambo movies
[Laughter]
all right guys well what do you think of
the cria 2 trailer I mean the fights
look great everything looks great again
about it I'm excited for it this could
be a pretty sweet film for my sweet film
are you excited to see the the Drago
Origin movie they've got it to make a
creat enough drug animatic Universum and
alway well you can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
belk subscribe buttons are essentially
broken and don't forget to get your
tickets to our live event link in the
description box people can watch me